so the word of the day is shallow so i'm
going to attempt to do for the next 10
minutes is
write a joke using the word shallow now
i've been a comedian over 12 years i've
interviewed over 400 comedians the name
of the game with joke writing
is volume the more you write the more
chances you have to find the next great
joke but a lot of times it's like you
write 20 jokes and end up keeping one so
i'm attempting to write one joke in 10
minutes
all for the sake of exercising that
riding muscles so
go easy on me
based on what the result may be but
let's be optimistic here
and the word of the day is shallow
on june 8th 2022
we're going to put 10 minutes on the
clock
here we go feel free to ride along with
me
during this 10 minute time or think of
tags and ideas and ways i could take
this joke as well
or write your own
but now
it is time my friends
engage
all right so here we go
so
the word of the day is shallow so
usually what i like to do to start off
with is just brainstorming things
that i associate with shallow so
it could be a shallow pool
shallow morals
you know uh shallow howl
is another like what do you think of
when you think of pool
uh i remember shallow pool i hit my head
as a child
when the pool was too shallow
i dove in and hit my head and
was like oh that hurt
uh but there's so many different things
you can associate with shallow shallow
puddle
and the first part of the joke rang
exercise is really just to brainstorm
just to get as many ideas connections
concepts out there as possible so even
shallow there may be a word play
shall
low
which could sound like
shalom
sorry if i'm misspelling that i'm a goya
but you know we're just we're just
associating here
so shallow shallow pool
shallow morals
morally shallow you're probably a jerk
um high standards
insecure
maybe even a bully
a shallow howl what do you think of jack
black
um
movie
maybe that reminds you of like a date
night or something you going to see it
maybe vhs you know there are no wrong
ideas
at this moment it's literally just
getting out ideas onto the page and the
more you get out there
the more you can pull from to kind of
start picking what you want so
as i'm looking at it right now
shallow
shallow pool
so also you can think of okay what are
the opposites so shallow end of the pool
shallow end
of pool
i don't know something with the shallow
end of the pool is resonating with me so
maybe there's what else is our deep end
what else you associate with the pool
lifeguard
so maybe there's something with a
shallow lifeguard
shallow lifeguard
[Music]
that only saves the pretty people
there could be something there
um shallow end like diving board
you associate with pool
adult swim
[Music]
um above ground pool so above ground
pool everything is shallow
shallow end
it's only shallow when it's an above
ground pool
the deep end
off the deep end is a phrase so it's not
only like associations
uh with words
but also maybe with um
certain themes
or um idioms perhaps so
off the deep end is a um a common phrase
so what are phrases that you can
associate with the word as well off the
deep end
and there's a good
a website called freedictionary.com
that you can search for all sorts of
idioms and uh synonyms and things like
that so maybe on next week's
uh maybe i'll pull that up tool up and
see what we can start to come up with
that way as well because this is still
all brainstorming here in kind of the
first half of it
shallow lifeguard
only saves pretty people that really
there's something there um but there's
also something to
the above ground pool always being
shallow because the pool was above
ground
public
pool
maybe an above ground pool is like a
public housing pool
housing
pool
um so i grew up with an above-ground
pool
uh at my dad and step mama's place
and they had a deck around it though so
it was fancy
um
diving hit my head maybe dive head
first
how else do you dive cannonball
hmm so i usually like to challenge
myself to write
personal
uh jokes what are true to me what are
always challenged comics to be like
what is unique to you that only you
could write about
but in this 10 minute exercise sometimes
it's just you have a funny idea and
you're right on that it's not
necessarily the most personal
but for me what's really sticking out
i mean the shallow lifeguard really um
there's something there and it's all
it's called a sense of humor so follow
that sixth sense follow
that sense
follow your instincts on this so my
instincts are kind of taking me in
there's something to shallow lifeguard
only saving pretty people
but there's also something to
an above ground pool
always being shallow
um
only being in the shallow end
so maybe all right let's let's let's
keep going here all right so in a setup
punch line we wanna start structuring
the joke here
so maybe it's um
my mom only
let me
kiddie pool is another one
a bathtub could be a funny
um
type of pool
pool
the game
pull the game as well another one
well i'm gonna let me swim
in the
shallow
end
above ground pool
kiddie pool
my mom only let me swim in the shallow
end
hmm
only let me swim in the shallow end
i don't know the lifeguard one just
seems to be sticking out to me more so
let's try to work that one so right now
we have a shallow lifeguard only saves
pretty people so how can we structure
that into a joke that's like a setup
punch
and in joke structure you know you set
up the audience to think in one
direction and then the punchline creates
a surprising second direction a
misdirection
so
let's see
shallow lifeguard only
saves pretty people
um
all right so let's just say
[Music]
just to personalize it
the lifeguard
save
pretty
people
shallow and because what do we associate
with shallow
uh someone who is shallow i don't know
what that means what are other ways
how is someone shallow
they
they're judgmental
um
isn't it shallow like they
in shallow how he only liked
pretty
women
um
shows your book by its color
oh okay kiddie pool
ah but that could go a wrong way i'm
just trying to think of
above ground pool
lifeguard and above ground pool
but too
shallow
okay
so maybe i tried
to date
the lifeguard
at
my local
above
ground pool
but she was
too
shallow
ah
tried to get a lifeguard at my local
above ground pool but she was too
shallow
above ground pool just isn't
that's just too wordy
but for 10 minutes i mean we got 10
seconds left here i tried to date
oh wait
i got offered
i got offered a job
as
all right 10 minutes is up maybe it's
like i got offered a job
as a lifeguard
public pool
cece says pool is all you need
but i wanted it to
assume shallow
maybe growing
growing up
i
growing up i was offered a
dang it well ten minutes are up so what
is it joel i tried to date the lifeguard
at my above ground pool
at my local above ground pool but she
was too shallow
i like that i mean in 10 minutes what
are you gonna do and i like that it's
self-deprecating i think a lot of times
comics
try to punch down and this is something
i learned from interviewing nate
barghettsi
was always make you the butt of the joke
he said whenever he made his wife the
butt of the joke
that the audience would react a little
hesitantly but when he was the butt of
the joke he framed it on himself that's
when they really
laughed and that's how he started to
find his voice so
for 10 minutes i tried to date the
lifeguard at my local above ground pool
but she was too shallow
i don't hate it
i don't hate it overall you know for 10
minutes but we do this every single
wednesday
live on our youtube channel at 10 a.m so
do subscribe and get notified when we do
this live stream as well as
three others we do throughout the week
and uh
we do this every day on our facebook
group as well where we post a new word
and comics around the world are writing
new jokes together so that's linked in
the description of this video if you
want to join us over there every single
day but
until then
that's the end of this right tim
have a good day y'all
cool